stocker ces aliments dans des bocaux en
verre composter ses épluchures de
légumes ou encore utiliser une brosse à
dents en bois l'office du développement
durable a aménagé un appartement
pédagogique et écologique de 100 mètres
carrés au Mureaux objectifs permettre au
public une visite immersive pour
promouvoir une consommation plus durable
faut savoir qu'on est quand même à plus
de 350 kg par personne et par an de
déchets et donc là l'idée c'est
justement de pas culpabiliser le public
mais de leur donner des conseils des
astuces un public présent déjà sensible
au sujet de la consommation durable la
période de confinement liée au covid-19
a permis un regain d'intérêt sur ces
questions environnementales tout ce qui
est produit d'entretien on fait aussi le
compost aussi on fait
on fait aussi attention aussi tout ce
qui est éclairage unitylle tout ce qui
est apparaît en veille on fait aussi
être aussi à l'économie d'eau nous
manque de consommation sont de plus en
plus
à l'achat à
consommer jeter alors qu'il faut essayer
d'avoir des nouveaux réflexes qui sont
plutôt
réparés réutiliser donner
faire maison aussi se mettre au
compostage permet jusqu'à 30% de
réduction de cette déchets organiques
une consommation plus responsable pour
une réduction des dépenses à travers des
gestes simples faire ces produits
ménagers maison passer au savon solide
ou
shampoing solide dans la salle de bain
ça va être des économies pour les
habitants organisé dans le cadre de la
Semaine européenne de la réduction des
déchets cet appartement pédagogique sera
ouvert jusqu'au 30 novembre au scolaire
et au grand public